it's the premiere of Niko's veigue
German made easy this online language
course helps people learn German in over
228 videos what's special about this
course is that it really brings all
different aspects together it offers a
compelling story
it has interactive exercises and a
mobile function it's available online
has nearly 230 courses that teach me
everything from A to Z and it's frees
slowly Inventure plays the main
character 22 year old nico from spain
who quits his studies and moves to
germany basically you learn how to
arrive in germany and speak the language
along with me it deals with all the
daily worries everyone has and everyone
knows
and communists I'm sure debunk at the
airport Niko meets a student and her
niece after losing his back they take
him in for a while here Lika learns
about daily life in Germany like how to
separate trash in a shared apartment the
videos come with about 14,000 language
exercises many of which are interactive
[Music]
in the beginners course a1 Niko learns
typical German greetings hey Lena
navigates hello oppa the self-study
course is available for mobile devices
and as an app all free of charge
[Music]
Paulo al-albani from Syria is learning
German with Niko's week what's great
about this program is that it's very
handy I can use it anytime anywhere
during my work break when I'm out and
about even on public transport
another case Oh God
from the beginners a1 to the advanced b1
course Nico's vague offers different
levels of difficulty during shooting
learning content was discussed with the
actors
Alabama my own firm dresses when
shooting a regular film actors often
adapt the text a bit to what feels more
natural to them that's why certain
grammar rules they had to keep to a
written right into the script so we
could later base grammar exercises on
them and you have a higher can listen
them at the done without you walnuts on
my own here it sentences that use the
conjunction of wool or although there
are two or three parts here that contain
this particular construction so I take
care that the actors don't change these
parts is astonished and like the same as
our poor villagers or kiss what are you
so much mercy disconnected and of course
there's also an exciting love story else
I think it's really interesting I just
want to keep watching to see what
happens next
Sean Vann buses was read by Syrian
Xiomara
you